I think there's blood coming out of me
coming out of my whatever that's where
your liver is that was a trump reference
because it's political season what was a
trump reference she had blood coming out
of her eyes blood coming out of her
whatever weight he said that he did
you sure did I registered to vote in
California like three days before the
deadline because I mailed it in guess
what I forgot to do what did you force I
knit but I'm all good
I
some to ribbons it's not a lot but I
think we have more somewhere else
I have camped I have I think you kind of
alluded that I'm getting there which I'm
excited about
I have a shotgun we'll see how this goes
doing pretty good yeah I mean my health
could be better screams grunting all
right so I have a gun shotgun shells a
blue herb for some reason I got a valve
handle do I need that's nice yeah you
want a valve handle Bashar okay other
than that I have more bullets which
they've conveniently abbreviated to M
bullets
Mikey bullets used about fifty six fifty
fifty six percent of your submachine gun
rounds against the eye and and a little
three awesome trouble yeah anyway I only
have one herb left sauce thing about mmm
you're fine with that I'd put the blue
one away cuz like I'm not caution I'm at
caution so I really can't take you're
right I don't like it all right so I
find myself getting more laid back the
farther into the game you get and that's
not good probably but we can't afford
like I don't have any more health so
it's like you know well what else I'm
gonna do anyway are you our lovely
viewers have been kind enough to guide
me a bit more on whether or not red
means that there's nothing left in there
you have to like leave the room there's
way more to it so let's just cool thank
you guys for your patience with me it's
my first time at least they're patient
it's my first
no I'm just kidding on all right where
am I going yeah there's that elevator in
the corner I've never been here this is
like a new territory for me well where
we're going I think cuz I'm going where
ADA was going because she's in trouble
am i doing this one right yeah yeah she
was in trouble remember yeah that's
where we left her people are
recommending ib8 along for Halloween
drop through ceilings so good
I already excuse I can get to wear a red
dress yeah you gotta follow her you'd
look good in a red dress I think a
change guns to shotgun or you bring the
shotgun isn't it oh you did so that
doesn't work yeah you gotta go check
your map quick I feel like there's a
branching path here
god I hope it has herbs
yeah wait hon go back to where the
elevators came from there's a weird
little oh yeah you're right I see it
I mind it'd be nothing but it could also
be something the penultimate no I think
it's just a weird little watch the wall
but I saw it I damn it Mary RPD yeah you
know me oh yeah I guess you're right
so there's this there's that little nook
by the ladder yeah yeah
this hallway to the left on your right
anyway because that's where a dhawan
ladder Nook wait I feel their spines in
here right yes and it was what two weeks
ago for like oh yeah I'm the sewers
I assume this is all right oh yeah the
fans on you did go here they're blue
herbs outside blue herbs might have been
helpful to bring I'm just kidding
why sorta I'm gonna find we got it just
don't get AIDS
whoa ah that's cool but I really need
help like I'll take it oh those are good
too you didn't help me with that I did
that on my own
pretty impressive well done I'm learning
I would give you like ten bucks but you
don't have any money it's okay Rach meds
hey like it freaks otherwise known as
where my god alligators love it
I don't look like that wait was I
supposed to go up the ladder cuz I want
a fan was on I would have sliced you up
okay so I'm going this way
slice and dice yeah I just go this way
and then you won't yeah wait there's a
dead guy check em out
feel him up pat him down could not have
tapped X more I don't know if the
audience hey guy when I wake up stop
doing that
am I taking a left or am I going
straight fork in the road huh yeah
go for it I don't know what does go for
it mean go for the yellow door they're
just kidding
I don't just go you're a bad person I'm
going left go this way first
unless you wanna play that spider Jesus
you're scaring me
well it's spiders are scary hmm are you
are you afraid of spiders a little bit
yeah should I take these no that's not
you can't take those you use that twice
and it's gone where's the [ __ ] hell I
need like green ones
normal mode son I wonder what you need
to do I'll use my gun this pistol is not
fitting Craig
oh those are herbs go run you need this
so badly yes mama
Hot Diggity Dog Show gun shells to your
left to Shogun now it should take both
herbs do I have room am I gonna be
picking anything I'll be coming back
through here cuz I really like I would
wait all of them there's some [ __ ] yeah
oh look and a little place to save this
is a nice place there's no safe box
though I don't think no no no no I
confirmed it there's not um what's this
for
it's the same thing okay bring it back
up oh that makes sense
well from what I remember you can go up
now and then bring it up so I would do
it oh you made do it now yeah alright
could be getting the word or wrong but
it's not a huge deal you just the valve
handle it up whenever you need to well
as long as there's not spiders are there
spiders I bet they're spiders what is he
doing
it's thinking about stuff
such a slow the game playing a little
bit scary thing scared I want to believe
that I can do this without taking any
more damage
ever claustrophobic arachnophobia dying
of phobic
well I listen for dogs now dogs be doing
in this laboratory tunnel wait a minute
okay their dogs no I understand
stop [ __ ] around you ready what's the
doral is it it will do or your sex
figure it out gas cylinder
eery Oh quick shoot at that water you
ready to roll run away I can't go back
to the gas cylinder what do you mean try
to open it yeah there you go
now now keep running and then shoot it
right yeah you theme down wait wait wait
wait I think you found me what am i
doing I can't pass it can I can I leave
oh my god I'm gonna die I'm gonna die
ah maybe the camera needs to be on it to
shoot it closer I mean yours ya know I
don't know go out fighting you know
there you go there you go oh well no
don't I got it it could've sworn that
kills you if you're that close I mean
I'm not quite I'm better than you how
[ __ ] awesome would be okay but really
alligators in the sewers what are you
thinking Capcom stop being so goddamn
brilliant I did it oh that was really
surprising holy crap put a sworn if
you're closer it killed you yeah got him
got him
yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah looks like that
thing from beetlejuice I hate that movie
and it terrifies me Michael Keaton like
I have had nightmares about beetlejuice
man I'm really glad I looked at that
thing on the door because I would not
have known what to do what you go into
the dumping area nato's just taking a
fat [ __ ] that's the dark the dollar read
is electronically locked safety lock
device for use in case of an emergency
will you release the electronic lock it
looks like the trash compactor room in a
new hope oh god I hope there's nothing
else in here wish granted who's this
who's this foxy lady hey girl stockings
update here yeah that's your fault [ __ ]
quietly quietly and it's just a gun glad
she heal me quietly on you little pansy
don't mention it
how is that - shouldn't be one could you
just heal them so much emotion I don't
well she's wearing Tom's John's deadly
uh what never mind
did you say John's dead no I said never
mind no before that don't want to talk
about it I said that's two I owe you no
after that but before never mind I could
go on I could keep going I know how
annoying would it have been if you got
all this way without cranking that
bridge yeah that was a good suggestion
wait horn no there's remember there's
stuff you couldn't use a Zadeh up there
yes yes I do
good I'm ADA
I can't use these Eagle yuh glia the
king of the Eagles dude that's so cool
that she healed me she's not so bad
Lord yeah play the next few games
Superman has many more yes been a while
but I saw Don today when he talked about
to completing our work he told me that
he thought maybe he had seen a giant
alligator in the sewer but I was like
you're on drugs he was sweating like a
horse do horses sweat a lot is that just
a weird comparison he was he was
sprinting like a llama [ __ ] taste
what's wrong with him she who's chief
irons the police chief Oh chief is a
title that's not his first name it just
seems like a weird Indian name um I
don't know what he's doing over there
but always looks grim the expression on
his face has been even more unsettling
than usual my guess is because dr.
beckons impossible request I rarely
drink because I'm on the graveyard shift
but I don't suppose I have much to
complain about since this is how I make
my living you drink more if you're on
the graveyard shift yeah it's all I
watch on the graveyard shift
I'll get totally toasted and
read it tried to joke with him and cheer
him up he pulled his gun and threatened
to shoot me I was able to calm him down
but that guy must have some serious
problems no no it can't enter the lab
without my help and my metal this is
what it means for the chief to serve and
protect umbrellas affairs that umbrella
is cheating on him with a parasol I have
been extremely cautious and that I'll
lose my job if anyone finds out about
this operation interesting c/o he'd got
I pulled a wishbone out of his so he got
he got murdered there's a bucket in your
stomach so he got murdered for being
involved in the Tokyo passageway when
they were done using him no they used
him he didn't just lose his job lost his
brain
so can I do it that's what I'm supposed
to do right stop the fan yeah should be
able to
oh no wait do you have to go back
through there no or maybe go to the
ladder maybe a tolls do it for you oh I
could be wrong you might just have to
mmm can I get killed if I go up there
it's not gonna let you I don't think
they'll be really fine so just get
killed by it I have to read you
everything wait a minute
oh is this yeah put the valve handle in
I promise it's so stupid
like how does it feel I know that is I
mean it's not game breaking if you don't
do that because you could just walk all
the way around but it's super dumb
that's really dumb yeah
oh my god that alligator I'm not over it
yes so I'll be in Spider alley when I do
this yes mm-hmm
so I need to get out of there so where
am I going I got all these medals then
the hallway you did not go down yet from
the spiders are you'll see when you that
one the blank one no the black hallway
you didn't go down I'm taking a left mmm
take a Lionel take a Lionel Ritchie
it is worth getting that coming back
into that room from the other side and
getting that green herb first though
[ __ ] what you have to go back the bridge
is up top no no I did bad uh he has a
green error back through the alligator
tunnel [ __ ] why did I just get it the
first time yeah I was worried that you
would have if there's something else you
found before the eagle medal I don't
know whatever it's worth going to get
I'm all I'm all mixed up it's been a
rough day it hasn't been a rough day
it's been a like a fun day with stream
stuff but it's yeah it's just been a lot
of talking where normally I would just
be buried in my computer trying to avoid
you specifically no no no not you the
I'm the best part of the day get to play
this game to show us your hot knowledge
I don't have as much knowledge of this
game as the first game but I like this
game a lot well you told me this one's
your favorite it is my favorite well no
premaster remake is my favorite but like
numbered entries and leaving aside
remake this my favorite is there any
secrets I don't think so
why is how is that also the dumping area
on the other side like that shouldn't
say dumping area on the dumping area
side that should say you are in the dump
you were leaving the dumping area I
don't think they thought that oh I also
didn't go through here nobody did
okay I can't God answer that it just
looks like you're supposed to go through
there oh the alligators wait
this isn't like the snake thing like I
blew that [ __ ] up
oh the top of his head is gone but the
bottom remains hmm
give me that plants lower the bridge
here now using your trusty valve handle
which you can put back in the box after
this now that you insert it in that
electrical panel and open that stop that
fan this is that permanent the fan yeah
yeah I think it really stops you go from
the other side but you won't really need
to got all you need babban it's gonna
depend all right so I might have a
basket of Eskimo going back to spy dolly
can then do that oh you haven't gone
through yet yeah i don't like spider
alley and also I forget where I'm
supposed to go cuz I'm spirally spider
Lea he spider really approached him with
8 legs it's an adverb okay okay so I'm
going to the left immediately you're
right what the cameras gonna yeah the
left on the map but the cameras gonna
change it'll be my humans left has been
gathering
ronita you dumb shits other thing to the
right eagle wolf do it I wonder what I
need what does that remind me of gumball
machines you put the quarter and things
like that does it does yep you're right
you're 100%
free up some spaces go go go go spy
rally [ __ ] spy rally peace out home
slices fighter hardly know her yeah it's
quiet in here
we're alone yeah but John's dead what
never mind
Oh what was that some hot ADA but right
off on screen some hot Leone blood right
up on screen
why are you following me
I'm such a creep she tells me how far
you can go before she starts to walk
walking walk this way
nicely ringing rock this can I ditch her
I think it's like a Sonic and Tails but
you fighting no matter how fast I answer
yeah just appeared first it doesn't look
good I'll give you that and I have
severe anxiety about not saving oh wait
no okay mmm
do I need to save
our sex quick and don't do it though max
whatever it is a control panel for the
sky tram will you turn the power on it's
only been a half hour yeah but we could
wing it
Shani yeah but the shotguns not gonna
play it safe it's not crazy far back
because you're just going back through
spider alley go in the safe box I need
to get which weapons because I'm trying
everything to save like another saved
yeah people watching could be like
freaking out telling me you don't need
to be coming back right come on play it
safe they're gonna freak out they know
that I could die where Zeta I lost her
dum dum dum
mmm that's what you meant to say right
that's what you wanted to say yeah dum
dum dum dum dum dum dum three of them
yes Oh Lord oh Lord
I hope that's right sometimes I just run
when there's spiders in the room do me
to get a better gun yeah I think there's
spiders in this room to check this
dude's body now you check his body now
that's drained I think you can where am
I going
not to the ladder okay so in that yellow
area pretty sure you did something now
wrong it's really dark go well he's
sentient
nope Leon are you wearing a bra no where
am I going
we just [ __ ] up we just made this
infinitely harder I gotta turn around
and I'll be dodging you've got enough
ammo to deal with them it's just yeah go
up there
it wasn't me looking down on us worth
just killing him right now cuz it's
gonna be hard to dodge later I guess all
of them just kill him
idiot idiot idiot like shooting zombies
in a barrel good get some that's the
phrase you too blondie eat it oh this is
the best I love doing it like this
stupid butt heads yeah um yeah make sure
their dads didn't waste bullets when you
come back to here looks like I mean fire
a couple rounds one okay you're good I
think keep the change you filthy animals
let's see okay I forget where I'm going
sorry I already have forgotten do you
remember
let's check out the map alright we're
going left or right left toward the
camera you have two and I think there's
more I think you have all of them I
think there might be like two more but I
don't even remember where they are it's
like the kind of thing where we kind of
screw ourselves right because we're like
yeah we'll get more you know like you
know if we can use we'll come back - so
put one greenair boom
yeah okay I'll wait Han mm-hmm check
double check that those the only
increments we have there's definitely
the only increments I have I promise
that's it
all right I don't know if you want to
save that I think you should want to or
do you want it sweet to you you brought
me all the way up no you need weapon you
need a weapon I think you do
wolf we'll explore this together what
weapon should I bring I would say that
tommy gun because then I have to bring
these that valve handle away Chuck gun
to bring and I could get rid of the gun
cuz I've killed the zombies I'll get rid
of the get rid of the handgun stuff yeah
and shotgun a case a regular trying to
think of the sequence of events that's
coming up I think I should save are we
winging it or not I need a decision no
go back to the I mean you didn't bring
the go back to think box quick I brought
everything you don't need you don't
bring ink ribbons oh right
there are ink ribbon you have a red and
green herb I'd say bring that in case
you get fun I do not have a red yeah you
do no I only have this a red and green
er yeah sorry I mixed red and green oh
you want the drugs yeah
damn you think shits gonna go down I
mean I could be misremembering secretive
events but you know safe all right here
we go sorry die if you die that'd just
be the episode Empire Strikes Back
didn't end in a happy way this could be
our the second in our trilogy sneeze
wait okay cool
should i okay I think it's on the return
trip with a trail yeah
hazy mem all right so there should be
all these should be dead they're gone
let's go check him though you all ready
yeah go check in
okay
look that was hunks squad I think who
wants some cool how long is it been 40
minutes now forgot I forgot about the
slides am I going up there yeah no wait
no here no sorry I forgot god the spider
is they just always surprise me god this
place just seems bad doesn't it just
seems like jizz is gonna get a trim
oh Jesus ADA that's how you get shot in
the face goddamn all right am i starting
this [ __ ] let's do it totally not gonna
die okay I'm building things up too
early but again it's my be prepared
little scared
you have prepped me for scare I'm gonna
[ __ ] punch myself in the face if you
get the other side
what is it move move move move you
didn't tell me what am i doing just
running that you hurt okay fine what is
that is that another one of those
thingies she'll see keep moving
move dumb dumb long did it move I got it
thank you
we made it look at looking like it like
it like it like it like that person
sitting
I see you've arrived yo you are in grave
danger
Narnia different different jokes
different way like it's just we're just
not just not in sync today ever
like a lighter
sorry I would just like to understand
the room here sigh okay so that's it
well wait what now look at the map again
oh and I read the yellow is 8 I keep
thinking that's it look to get door it
does look like a door behind ya ya ya ya
ya ye here we go
I hear [ __ ] oh ho I hear you a third
group try to get that head shot with a
shotgun I think they are but twitching
does that mean to us calm are they
I'm afraid what if they are like right
next to me he's got cinder blocks for
feet all right I'd like to see the
layout of the room ah yeah I'll just go
forward and back up blue man if you can
that like hopefully that triggers I'm
following you
so cheeks oh wait
can I shoot her can I waste her ammo
yeah my weight dum-dum let her shoot
then go for it
oh yeah do that just back up let her
shoot
hey that you take care of this see the
yes I'm moving up that's how it's done
ADA stare the body down oh you can get
out you double headshot with them
there's two yeah what if there's someone
behind me good go for that go for that
[ __ ] he's too far behind there mine
still felt good oh yeah you want to come
out now
okay sorry I was I was peeing what have
you been up to what happened kill
everybody
I don't think good about this layout no
okay so there's a secret up there maybe
check it out I you know I think I am I'm
also gonna come Benny yeah comon thank
you
Susan G Komen Race for the Cure some are
you doing here
it's a breast cancer awareness yes
that guy's not dead yeah check him out
I don't know check him out excuse me sir
are you dead
excuse me sir I mean that's weird though
he didn't give me an item or okay cool I
was like that's weird
wait yeah take it rip yeah you're you're
like voice doesn't make sense you don't
know what you're saying
okay
I hear him I need to understand the room
layout okay
it appears to be a door moving along
beside you come on that's so dangerous
those pricks hey what's up you can give
a [ __ ] he's gonna keep walking Wow
oh it's another Fork those [ __ ] they
did that on purpose
I'm Lauren even those not the only Zambo
nice nice nice nice nice nice nice nice
nice nice what yeah I got nose ooh
out of my way metal guitar riff man its
wheeze you're gonna shoot him in the
head I hope you're happy that's what you
get come on I try to let her shoot him
can she take damage
[ __ ] him up [ __ ] him up much easier it's
not good I don't think yes but here she
soaked on the way she killed him because
she's she's been calling this whole game
she's a little too calm yeah I let her
[ __ ] him up to do yo thang girl look at
that Luke see you baby
shooting that song we make a good team
alright he's dead yeah that way is the
non doorway what oh so I want to go to
check that first you know they're gonna
do is I mean others audience moans make
him alive cool
we already have a bunch [ __ ] it take
them is there gonna be a place for these
cuz I'm running out of slots here take
it really take it
why the [ __ ] would you take it
complicated today
a ladder the road such AG ladder company
that's from santa claus where did that
why did that i don't know what how you
know things that come out of your magnum
was not necessary let's move past that
though whatever i was we didn't get any
Oh are there save distance here there
should be yes oh we did it
might be a good yeah that's good no
that's a good forty five is that bad
we're doing them like again we've
mentioned others they're right in front
of it we do them based on when it's a
good time oh yeah you know cuz like
that's just smart yeah so i don't mind
ending it in forty minutes if that's the
smartest place to throw a hard sabe on
this file wait check those new cabinets
check around this room first got it
girlfriend
Oh more rounds and shotgun rounds yeah
my weight got a couple more rounds next
to it
some some more rounds I think they how
can I have some more nothing I think
there's killing me smalls yeah oh that's
that's house right oh man yeah dude I
feel like I've been stressing but also
why are they giving you so much health
all right cool save that ish so that
cash progress those super plus you
didn't have to use anything to heal what
if you healed right before a but you got
to eat up that would have been shitty I
would have been so mad that's like the
perfect first person [ __ ] right
where you're like I really need to heal
because you got greener spore you got a
first person like first time it is
misleading but it's like they gave you
herbs before you see a de without
someone telling me that I would have
100% say like healed up and then been
furious
like this games cruel toys with you you
and your emotions and your sense of
super it really does anyway that is a
new episode of resident evil we will be
back with the penultimate episode
Resident Evil 2 Resident Evil 2 also you
guys ghosts were on the left this time
what's up that was pretty weird mixing
it up just felt like it no I was like
that when I got in and I was too lazy to
change it just click and drag it I think
all right wait can I can i play with it
quick yeah
wow I'm sure you guys like to see that
how this awesome behind the scenes